en quelques clics des algorithmes
prouvent que cette image est falsifiée
parmi eux celui créé par une jeune
yvelinoise Tina nicuka et doctorante en
mathématiques appliquées le but de ma
recherche c'est de créer des algorithmes
qui donc sont capables de savoir ce qui
est arrivé à une image et donc dans
détecter les anomalies donc c'est une
image je sais qu'il est qu'elle a subi
telle opération parce que l'image subit
une suite d'opérations mathématique si
je sais qu'elle a subi telle opération
particulière je peux voir localement
dans l'image s'il y a des parties qui
n'ont pas subi la même opération un
algorithme développé au sein du Centre
Borély laboratoire de l'École normale
supérieure de Paris Saclay est mis en
pratique avec l'Agence France Presse
bien loin de la recherche en blouse
blanche Tina NICU café partie des
chercheuses distinguées de la 16ème
édition du Prix Jeune Talent en France
de la Fondation L'Oréal
ce prix c'est une reconnaissance de ma
recherche mais encore plus de ce que je
fais en dehors de la recherche classique
j'ai pas je pense pas avoir ce prix
parce que j'ai soumis des conférences
j'ai des articles je pense que j'ai
supprimé pour
l'étape en plus que j'ai fait de
transmettre les sciences au grand public
Tina nicuka va bientôt soutenir sa thèse
prochain défi de la doctorante et de son
laboratoire travailler sur les deep fake
des trucages utilisant l'intelligence
artificielle